boiler alert if you haven't seen the
season 1 finale of unreal well it was
unreal and oh so good we killed somebody
yeah
let's not do that again the lifetime hit
has been full of jaw-dropping moments in
its first season so how will they avoid
the sophomore slump in season 2 actually
I hadn't thought of it until now I'm
gonna go throw up I'll be right back
kidding aside the casseon producers tell
ET they have a plan
the sophomore slump to me often happens
because you're reacting the fans
reacting to you we can't do that we just
have to go back and do what we did
before which is put ourselves in a
little bubble and try to be as
despicable and as juicy and as real as
possible and you know not not gonna do
it feedback here's what we know the
everlasting format will return what we
are conveying to is sticking with
everlasting format probably with a twist
with a different suitor or suits rest
whoever it was might be and we're really
new trust I think it'd be amazing to
have a female and then have us be
surrounded by that many more men and
then let's see how we treat them that's
right
season 2 casting is still under wraps
but the fan favorites seem game for a
comeback I want Brittney to come back
and be the suit rest' for everlasting
season 2 high-five love it love it
there's definitely a possibility that
Adam might show up again I would love to
but it's also gonna be pretty remarkable
to have a whole new set of contestants
you know if there's a possible spin-off
show did she just say spin-off show it
might be everlasting in paradise we've
talked about Hawaii was really fun um we
also are really passionate about dealing
with the race issue a little bit more
because something that we breathed over
but we feel really strongly about and so
there's some really interesting
potential casting for that
as for the comparisons to that other
show about finding love I'm gonna start
off with a joke do it knock-knock two
bachelorettes
that's the children those will continue
the play thing is at one point we had
pitch an idea in-house that there be two
female suitors yes and then they did it
on the show we were like we have a mole
unreal will return to lifetime in 2016